Speaker 1: All right.
I deliberately separated out this particular
portion of Donald Trump's latest unhinged
speech that he gave or statement to the camera.
Not really a speech, kind of more just a video.
I don't even know what to call it at this
point.
It's how he's communicating with his so-called
followers.
I wanted to separate it out because there's
a much bigger story behind it that's building
among the Republican Party at the top of the
show.
I told you that there are many DeSantis potential
mega-donors who are furious with De Santos
and getting away from him.
But there's another movement that's going
on.
There's a movement that's going on from within
the Trump camp to pound and crush DeSantis
so badly.
Now, before he even announces with the goal
of getting DeSantis to not even try.
Wait until 2028 or forget about it altogether
is sort of the idea.
The right wing Washington Times reports DeSantis
has Trump campaign's foot on his throat, seen
as true threat to ex-president's 2024 hopes.
And the idea of what's going on here is that
Trump, on some level, does worry that if DeSantis
did get into the race, that doesn't mean DeSantis
would win, but it would be a fight that maybe
Donald Trump doesn't want to have.
And so the idea is maybe Trump can get DeSantis
to not even get involved in this race altogether.
And this brings us to this particular moment
from the speech, from the video.
I don't know.
I keep calling it a speech from the video
that Donald Trump published yesterday where
he just ranted and raved about the Santos's
poll numbers.
And this is considered part of the effort
to prevent the contested primary.
Trump still winning by toe in most polls.
But what would be a contested primary and
instead open the door for Trump to face off
against twos, threes and fours, as we call
them.
People polling two, three and 4% and have
a much easier path to the Republican nomination.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: I think lots of job requests from
people currently working for the Social Security,
Medicare cutting.
The sanctimonious campaign.
Ron's poll numbers are dropping so fast and
furious that many people are speculating he's
not going to run.
He just hired kiss of death.
Jeff Roe.
He's the kiss of death.
I can tell you a lot of the people that we
defeated who were represented by Jeff Roe,
kiss of death, who dropped young Kim, you
know who Young Kim is to see if he can help
and he's going to help run.
But I don't think he's going to help a much
because I'm leading in Texas by 42 points,
Iowa and New Hampshire by a lot overall by
close to 40 and by ten against the scammer
Joe Biden.
Speaker 1: Okay, so Trump is not wrong.
Trump is genuinely polling really, really
well in the Republican primary.
And if you look at just the trends, this is
real Clear Politics is a chart of the trends.
I'll describe to you what's going on.
You see a purple line, which is Trump, and
you see a green line, which is DeSantis.
And you do indeed see that starting around
March 11th and accelerating dramatically around
March 27th.
Donald Trump has gained significantly in the
Republican primary polls and Ron DeSantis
has started to decline significantly.
And the decline doesn't seem to be stopping
right now.
I already spoke with you earlier in the show.
There's a number of different reasons that
this is going on.
There's a Washington Post article after High
Flying Start.
DeSantis Hits Stumbling Blocks on the Road
to 2024.
This article does mention the Republican mega-donors
that are moving away from Ron DeSantis.
This mentions that many Republicans aren't
thrilled with the six week abortion ban.
Again, it's potential mega-donors.
Maybe not because they personally are pro-choice,
but they recognize the direction that the
country is and continues to be has been moving
and continues to move on that issue.
They believe that the Sanders's is making
unforced errors, which include not only signing
that abortion ban, but having to clarify the
comments on Ukraine being a territorial dispute.
As I mentioned, he's striking Republicans
as distant in personal interactions and on
and on and on, but he's still in second place.
So there is now sort of this overt.
It's no longer.
It's no longer a secret.
I don't know that it ever was.
But it's no longer a secret that Trump would
like to knock out DeSantis and get him not
to even run.
Is that likely to happen?
There's two different perspectives on this
perspective.
Number one is, even if you're only polling
30% or what was it exactly?
And that Real Clear Politics, DeSantis is
polling on average 24% right now, even if
you're only polling 24%.
It's difficult to get away from running when
it will put you on the national stage up against
Trump, which is a great opportunity to get
attention, which can backfire if Trump makes
fun of you in a way that's effective but gives
you a ton of national attention and you probably
to some degree think to yourself.
I mean, listen, Nikki Haley announced and
she's polling what is she polling?
She's polling 3%.
And, you know, Ramaswamy announced and he's
polling 1%.
I haven't announced anything yet and I'm polling
24%.
I'm sure I can build that number if I actually
announce and run.
So on the one hand, that would be the argument
that makes it very difficult for you to say,
I'm not going to run.
On the other hand, if you're patient, it does
seem logical to me to think, you know, I'm
polling 24%, but what's my ceiling is most
of the, you know, Haley, Pompeo, Cheney, is
all of that just going to go to Trump, who's
already over 50%?
Do I really have a shot here or do I have
a better shot at waiting until 2028?
What might interfere with that is that there
is uncertainty.
You don't know what will happen to your political
career between now and 2028.
And so so maybe it is difficult for DeSantis
to get away with from it.
I don't think that it is 100% that DeSantis
runs, but I think it is the most likely outcome
at this time.
And from the people I've spoken to in Florida
who are sort of like tangentially surrounding
the DeSantis camp, there is a lot of confidence
that the decision has already been made by
DeSantis, that he's not going back and that
no polling collapse short of going to zero
is going to dissuade him from running.
We'll watch it and we'll follow it very closely.